[Musique]
oui
et
saviez mauduit bonjour bonjour merci
d'être sur le plateau de tv soixante dix
huit pour ce vip qui vous est
entièrement consacré vous êtes ici car
vous êtes l'auteur d'un ouvrage
récemment paru qui s'appelle la
véritable histoire des impressionnistes
et qui par chance évoque de nombreux
peintres qui ont habité dans les
yvelines voilà notre lien d'abord je
vais vous présenter on vous connaît de
toute façon vous êtes chroniqueur
historique à l'émission qui s'appelle 28
minutes oui ce soir arte tous les jours
à quelle heure or il est à peu près
20h40 quand je passe ma petite chronique
d'histoire et c'est une chronique
d'histoire liée à l'actualité donc dans
28 minutes avec elisabeth cas très bien
et vous avez aussi commis pas mal de
chronique sur france inter oui on se
souviendra des missions avec philippe
collas dudit chroniques ont en général
voilà vous êtes agrégé d'histoire oui
vous avez écrit une thèse antithèse
ouais j'ai fait ma thèse commis ma thèse
la maison de l'empereur précisément sur
la cour de napoléon iii sur second
empire ce qui est logique d'ailleurs
pour expliquer pourquoi j'ai été vers
les impressionnistes alors y venir base
à temps plein il n'y a pas dix neuvième
en plein second empire d'accord alors
votre ouvrage s'intitule la véritable
histoire des impressionnistes pourquoi
véritable stora ce qu'est une fausse
histoire déjà c'est une bonne question
en crète vous savez j'ai souvent
repérées que les impressionnistes
étaient considérés comme des figures
tutélaires ne serait ce que par le nom
quand on dit monnaie canton des renoir
n'importe où dans le monde tout de suite
d être formidable et puis par le prix
aussi c'est quelque chose d'un peu plus
bas quand même le prix ben oui on voit
les chats drame avec chiffre atteint
lors des enchères pour tout de suite ça
fait rêver et pourtant on oublie
facilement que les impressionnistes ont
fait scandale
bon dieu le sociologue c'est un peu
sérieux mais quand il a écrit son manet
à la écrit une phrase que je trouve
magnifique il dit qu' aujourd'hui ce qui
fait scandale en vain c'est que ça a pu
faire scandale tellement ça nous paraît
une évidence on est dans les musées on
voit des oeuvres impressionnistes
c'est toujours sublime et d'ailleurs les
salles les exposition consacrée aux
impressionnistes sont remplies de monde
donc on ne comprend même plus pourquoi
ces gens là ont fait scandale donc il
était nécessaire de revenir à la base de
faire de l'histoire un chiite historien
du social afin de faire de l'histoire
sociale de voir pourquoi ces gens là on
poser autant de problèmes et puis la
véritable histoire des impressionnistes
et qu'il faut oublier aussi derrière ces
figures tutélaires
oublier que ce ne sont pas que des
peintres majeurs ce sont aussi des
hommes des femmes qui parfois ne sont
pas exceptionnelles
humainement parlant olala money money
non mais c'est vrai le coup tempo mais
il fait un enfant à camille il la laisse
tout seul la pauvre à paris va pendre
alex a dispensé ses artistes c'est un
peu le problème des artistes des gens
très bien pour ça et bien sûr alors là
on a la carte derrière nous donc la
vallée de la seine avec différents
différentes villes ou villages qui donc
sont dans les yvelines dans lesquelles
ils ont demeuré mais moi j'aimerais bien
qu'on remonte un tout petit peu alors
avant que les impressionnistes arrive on
était dans une peinture romantique
académique comment on peut dire écoutez
l'histoire de l'art au 19e siècle est
complexe mais c'est pour cela qu'elle
est intéressante pour simplifier on a
une peinture classique au début du 19e
siècle sont des peintres comme david
qu'on connaît bien son magnifique dans
les années 1820 30 on a ce mouvement
romantique de la croix et plein d'autres
peintres qui bouleverse complètement les
canons et qui sont bien acceptés et puis
ensuite d'autres mouvements apparaissent
alors le naturalisme l'école de barbizon
vers la forêt de fontainebleau de
l'autre côté des yvelines et mais dans
les années 1850 ce mouvement qu'on
appelle pas encore impressionnistes un
peu attendre ouais il lui serait 74 pour
qu'il prenne un mot quand on dit mais
qu'est ce que c'est que cette peinture
sans doute une impression passé de
l'impressionnisme et cette peinture qui
apparaît dans les années 1860 sous le
second empire c'est pour ça que moi je
me suis intéressé à cette question est
formidable parce qu'elle a un écho
jusqu'à nos jours on le sait bien je
suis une vraie question se pose en tout
cas pour moi à liqueur ou historiens
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pour que des
peintres à ce moment précis de
l'histoire se disent nous allons changer
la manière de pain nous allons casser
l'art officiel l'art académique qu'est
ce qui s'est passé c'est un monet renoir
qui un beau matin se réveille et se
disent tiens on va inventer
d'impressionnisme c'est pas comme ça
lance donc père comment est bien fallait
remettre en place ce qu'on a fait avec
cédric lemagnen nico hauteur dans ce
livre on a remis en place oui panoplie
au late vous l'avez écrit avec cédric
lemagnen et directeur à la maison du
tourisme de giverny
installé claude monet donc voilà c'est
fallait remettre en place le contexte
pour comprendre pourquoi des tensions
dans le mille 2 art et tousser certains
peintres à rompre avec l'art académique
et à faire une proposition différente
drôlement culotté qui s'appelle
l'impressionnisme d'accord et puis aussi
peut-être l'avènement de la photographie
qui fait que de toute façon si on
voulait quelque chose d extrêmement
réaliste et est représentatif et les
précis autant prendre une photo sajoo
c'est évidemment son camp d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas un hasard si la première
exposition des impressionnistes en 1874
se tient dans les ateliers de 1 ha d'ar
le grand photographe mais vous avez
raison en disant ça c'est vraiment un
des poids au coeur de la question à quoi
ça sert de représenter un arbre avec
toutes ses feuilles
si tu fais une exclusion en ajoutant une
photo vous fera l'arbre très bien et
al'inverse notre cerveau identifie un
arbre vous regardez un arbre dessiné par
un enfant il connaît toutes faites un
arbre qui a quand même une autre
question qui se pose c'est que le
photographe ne peut pas tout faire un
photographe en tout cas dans ces années
là les débuts de la photographie qui
prend en photo de l'eau en mouvement ça
donne de l'eau figé par les
impressionnistes et 10 mai nous par la
peinture on peut aller plus loin on peut
montrer le mouvement de l'eau voilà
donner l'impression du mouvement et leur
propre vision voilà c'est une période
très courte finalement très très riche
très important c'est de ça a duré de
1874 1886 à peu près sûr voilà il ya eu
différents salons ils ont été recette
est quoi ce système de salon en duo vous
avez le monde et le monde de la radio
ils ont tenu par l'académie des
beaux-arts et par l'école des beaux-arts
raccord avec le prix de rome stehlé
gardien les gardiens du temple de l'art
c'est à dire que l'arrêté un peu figé
avec des figures comme des peintres
jérôme de la roche sont un petit peu
oublié aujourd'hui qu'ils reviennent sur
le devant de la scène ce que sont des
artistes majeurs mais qui avait figé ce
monde de l'art et certains pains qui
voulait entrer dans ce système des
salons les salons c'est très simple tous
les ans un salon officiel était présenté
à présenter toutes les oeuvres donc les
artistes envoyait des toiles un jury de
l'académie et l'école des beaux-arts
sélectionnait
mais être exposé au salon assurer des
commandes officielles
vivre et des ventes atones à une
commande officielle souvent on a une
commande après de particulier donc sa
porte en être exclu du salon cystite
extrêmement difficile du coup napoléon
iii à proposer un salon des refusés oui
il a senti la pression qui allait
pousser les impressionner alors c'est
plus complexe napoléon iii en fait n'y
connaissez rien leur faut être honnête
ce type l'un non mais napoléon iii est
un homme sans doute de son temps mais
qui la voyez pas tellement mouvement
impressionniste net le larron quartier
pas son truc et même la peinture c'est
pas son truc mais ils sont une
contestation et comme empereur
bonapartiste soucieux de toutes les
classes de la société donc de tout le
monde de l'art il crée un mouvement
l'oeil ça l'idée refusé pour ceux qui
ont été refusés au sein d'accor très
bien est ce que dit aussi ce qui est
après on va passer au peintre nommément
nous y voilà c'est un critique d'art qui
disent à ses tableaux il fallait trouver
le point d'optique je vous à julie cette
expression c'est en fait on les regarde
différemment c'est un nouveau regard
kong et des tableaux qu'on doit regarder
différemment enfin lui il expliquait
qu'il fallait les voir de très longs à
traverser la rue en face quasiment on
s'est beaucoup moqué d'eux vous savez il
y avait vraiment une révolution à une
forme esthétique qui était entré dans
les moeurs qui était accepté bon bah par
les dominants et par les dominants et
les élites aristocratiques mais aussi
par la bourgeoisie nous sommes au début
de la révolution industrielle et soyons
vraiment honnête et pour préciser les
impressionnistes ont changé notre
manière de voir c'est à dire qu'il ya
des choses qu'on ne voyait pas avant
tout ils ont réussi par leur peinture à
trouver des petits détails je vous en
donne qu'un exemple mais il est
fascinant jusqu alors les ombres été
noir sur les tailles nombre et noir les
impressionnistes ont ce gély de voir que
l'ombre n'est jamais noir une utilise
pas noirs longs et de la couleur à sion
grille de l'objet le livre est orangée
et bien l'ombre du livre aura une petite
tente de renvoyer sont des choses ça
qu'on n'avait pas vu et puis ils ont vu
les paysages comme jamais
ça serait bien qu'on en vous regarde un
petit peu et qu'on en parle parce que
justement dans les yvelines nous avons
eu la berthe morisot à femme
exceptionnelle qui était la compagne de
manette voilà enquêter la compagne de
manet pas égarer puis à près de gênes
son frère voilà donc là nous avons deux
tableaux qui sont bas bougival après
nous avons auguste renoir et félicien
rops et toujours à bougie
l'algérie et voilà madame accès plus
tardives on est presque oui un peu trop
vite mais pourquoi bougival
c'est la question pourquoi la vallée de
la seine pourquoi mais non il ya un vrai
fait historique c'est à dire que nous
sommes à un moment où la révolution
industrielle permet des déplacements
vous avez raté la première ligne de
chemin de fer le paris saint germain en
laye donc c'est plus facile de se
déplacer ensuite le train permet
l'arrivée de marchandises du vin par
exemple qui vient du sud sauf que à part
il ya ce qu'on appelle l'octroi vous
savez c'est comme une barrière douanière
a relevé un tout petit peu moins cher
quand vous êtes hors de paris ok c'est
mieux d'aller s'encanailler à chatou et
surtout ce que faisaient ces peintres
connus que faisait pas les princes les
peintres précédent banon s'était de
peindre à l'air libre oui c'était ça la
révolution si c'était d'aller mettre son
chevalet dans la campagne et donc ils
avaient besoin de jolies campagnes d'eau
jardin etc vous avez un précurseur c'est
turner le peintre anglais qui en 1832
déjà payet le château de
saint-germain-en-laye lui ils avaient
compris cette idée mais c'est un peu
anglo saxons de d'aller dans la nature
mais le but était de peindre la nature
édifiante peu importe si c'était
ressemblant avec la montagne soit
splendide impressionnante les
impressionnistes reprenne ses idées à
qu'on retrouve aussi avec l'école de
barbizon vers fontainebleau d'année au
plein air les impressionnistes veulent
pas le paysage tel qu'il est c'est à
dire que quand n'importe qui renoir
monet peint un paysage c'est ce paysage
là un moment précis avant vous aviez un
paysage paysage en naturel vous voyez
vous aviez un ancien signé par pizarro
et bien c'est la vue de l'ancien ça ne
peut pas être ailleurs voyez il ya cette
vision du paysage avec le souci du
détail et je vous dis parfois le souci
de leur c'est ne pas la même lumière oui
et est surtout alfred sisley apprendra
les inondations 1876 voilà c'est juste
magnifique bon écoute et il nous reste
presque plus de temps a dit moi
j'encourage tout le monde à lire ce
livre à l'offrir c'est bientôt noël
attention vous en a parlé et c'est très
intéressant vous relier tout ça avec le
contexte historique du moment on apprend
plein de choses et même si on n'est pas
fan de cette peinture impressionniste
finalement on peut être n'êtes que fan
de cette histoire de quotas mais oui se
sont révoltés qui ont sacrifié leur vie
à la peinture qui n'ont pas fait
beaucoup d'argent à l'époque
malheureusement mais après oui mais bon
sont devenus des grands notables qui
c'est vrai qu'avec cédric on a voulu y
mettre de l'humour parce que l'art n'est
pas juste si nice ou extatique l'ars est
aussi drôle santé les gens là étaient
des fous furieux avait été près du bourg
était plein d'humour et avec de très
belles histoires se valent voilà merci
xavier produits et à très bientôt pour
un autre ouvrage avec plaisir merci
[Musique]
et